do you guys hear the freedom story no
freedom
you go oh here we go you guys ready for
this
just going nuts right now fox news
kamala harris repeatedly told
freedom story now facing plagiarism
accusations i won't waste your time
friends i'll give you a simple version
before reading this she apparently did
an interview where she said she was like
a civil rights march when she was a
toddler
in a in a stroller and fell down and
then her mom saw her fuss and said what
do you want she goes freedom
yes and then everyone clapped that
happened and then
apparently this was plagiarized off of a
martin luther king junior story where he
said he saw a little girl at a civil
rights march
giving you know fuss and a white cop
said you know what do you want and she
goes feed them
so i actually look if you told me a
little kid
yelled something they heard their
parents yell and they struggle to say it
properly i believe
i do i want to know but but kamala
harris that's
she said i remember i was i was one year
old and i was in a stroller and i yelled
freedom
sure you did see i want to know if um
she actually remembered it right
like she thought it was her or or like
if if see there's three there's three
scenarios here
uh either she completely plagiarized
martin luther king
which is possible that's the most likely
scenario
the second is that she remembered
saying that or her parents
told her yeah that's that's what
happened and either it happened or they
read
the the the article and then they just
kind of i have some ideas but let me
read this
so fox news reports kamala harris had
previously told the anecdote about her
younger self crying out for
freedom that's w-f-e-d-o-m which has
sparked accusations of plagiarism in her
books
quote my mother used to laugh when she
told the story about a time i was
fussing as a toddler
she leaned down to me and asked kamala
what's wrong what do you want and i
wailed back freedom
harris wrote in her 2010 book smart on
crime okay harris also detailed her
younger self demanding freedom
in her 2019 book the truths we told
apparently
appropriated and anecdote amazing right
an anecdote first told by civil rights
icon martin luther king jr
when she was interviewed by l magazine
for a feature that was published october
at the height of the 2020 presidential
race
harris has repeatedly boasted of her
parents involved into the civil rights
movement of the 1960s
in the interview she recalled
accompanying them two marches as a
toddler here we go here's the story
senator kamala harris started her life
life work young writer ashley c ford let
off the piece
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family as she remembers being
wheeled through
an oakland california civil rights march
in a stroller with no straps
with her parents and uncle at some point
she fell from the stroller
and the adults caught up in the rapture
of the protest just kept marching
by the time they noticed little kamala
was gone and doubled back she was
understandably upset
my mother tells the story about how i'm
fussing harris told the magazine and
she's like baby what do you want what do
you need
and i just looked at her and i said
freedom after the interview resurfaced
monday twitter user
engels freddie and andre domes
contributing editor of the canadian
publication mcleans noted that harris's
story resembled one told by king in 1965
interview
published in playboy maybe kamala harris
is trying to make it seem like he was
talking about her
like martin luther king jr was telling a
story that was about her i'm going to
err on kama's side on this one because i
think a lot of people in the 60s wanted
freedom
and a lot of kid people said that around
their kids so the kids just repeated
them yeah well
so um so i um i think that
at this point we can have we have to say
that
we know two things for sure one
nobody read kamala harris's books right
for sure yeah definitely
because otherwise this would have been
amazing oppo research for any democrat
it would have come out a long time it
would have come out a long time ago it
was 2010 she wrote this
yeah the book was 2010. nobody read
those books did you read those books i
didn't i didn't know they existed
and also and also i'll point out the one
thing i can say is
factually true but is framed not so well
is when the writer says
she laughs from her gut the way you
would with family yes
kamala harold laughs at in opera like in
inappropriate moments
like there was one where she was being
called out i can't remember why i think
i think she was being called out for
criticizing biden as racist and she's
like
and then she just stops and she's just
staring smiling like this weird grin and
it's like
stop laughing this is inappropriate
not the time but she laughs it's weird
or when she was confronted about
supporting biden when she was viciously
attacking him before
same thing it was a debate but but she
also
in that interview it was the one like
right after they
they were officially nominated she said
it's a distraction like no it's a thing
that happened yeah
you want to you want to talk about the
thing that happened or you want to just
write it off
did somebody tell kamala harris and
hillary clinton
if you're ever asked a question just
laugh for no reason because they both
would do it
i'm so they're bought off and they're
nervous
i don't know about that i think you know
look i'll tell you why
maybe kamala hara said this freedom
story she she's got narcissist
i think she's a narcissist i think she's
an arrogant authoritarian narcissist
and when she like look look at look at
uh joe biden's plagiarized how much oh
so now
it's no surprise to me even buildback
better is not his isn't that hilarious
right
nope this is original for kamala and i
really want to say this because this is
something that i just discovered
so the last civil rights march was in
1963.
kamala harris was born in 1964.
if you'll recall her details about being
in college and listening to who was it
tupac snoop dogg snoop dogg she was
listening to me
is the last surviving rapper that she
likes you said the last civil rights
march was 1963 before she was born yes
so but like what was that civil rights
march um i i think that was the march
on damn it died with the king i think it
was uh martin luther when did
martin luther king junior died yeah the
16th 63 yeah i think yeah
no no no could it have been no he didn't
die the same year that jfk died no he
was like
68 i think it might be
that's a good story there were civil
rights protests happening forever i mean
i know she's trying to make it seem like
it was the civil rights movement right
but there were a bunch of you know
there's always protests for something
but why do you tell that story
you and and re repeatedly because it's
weird because you want to
because you're narcissistic obviously
but you also want to say
you know i've been you know when i was a
child that i wanted
that i wanted to fight for something
whether it's brian williams hillary
clinton they always
lie about so many different and so many
different things and building on on top
of what you were saying specifically
she was described as a ruthlessly evil
human being when she was a prosecutor in
california i mean the stories that come
out of her
knowing people are innocent ruining
people's lives
knowingly just to get ahead she will do
anything
to get ahead literally figuratively she
was keeping people in prison beyond
their parole
to use them as cheap labor to put out
fires no less
now i remember when i was three years
old and i
ran into a burning building to save a
bunch of puppies because it's just what
a hero does
and i can't believe kamala harris would
ever say something so so
egregious and exaggerated another thing
that everyone clapped by the way that's
another thing that you got the
presidential uh medal of freedom i did
yeah twice
yeah yeah another thing people need to
realize
is that prosecutors are rewarded when
they have a high
win case and not many lost cases this is
a totally
horrible system bill hicks had this skit
about marketers and what they should
do to themselves i think that's
definitely translated
though and i'm not saying it i'm just
saying he had a point maybe maybe it
could be
brought over to some prosecutors but
that's a system by the way was bill
hicks right yeah it was before he
started in fours
uh yeah before before the male vitality
yes okay um but when we look at the
prosecutor system
here there is something that does
deserve to have a legitimate
conversation we do deserve to talk about
these issues because there are
injustices
just like with kamala harris when she
was prosecutors there are
problems within our legal system that do
need to be addressed
that some of these protesters want to
change but they don't understand
their movement is being hijacked by
those individuals that literally make
the system as bad as it is
two plagiarists joe biden it's like i i
you know
one of my favorite memes is it's like 50
years in congress and it's a picture of
like you know biden and it's like
how long has has kamala been in like 10
or so
it was like you got you got 2016. you oh
really
yeah oh is it a senator you've got uh uh
you've got
nadler schumer you've got pelosi and
biden and it's like
decades in congress now's the time
they're gonna fix everything yeah
everything else was just a dry run all
right they were just they were there
getting you know practicing a little bit
sharpening their their axe before they
were getting ready for that you know
timbering
now now is the time finally
uh so that's why planets have aligned
you just don't get it
yeah yeah yeah you know it's the time
it's just the right moment
it's it's army i feel like when atlantis
got flooded
sorry this is a bit of a segue but i'm
bringing it back i'm talking about
the entire world got like wiped out and
reset
okay before atlantis got flooded
atlantis was the giant king that ruled
the earth apparently they had
circumnavigate navigated the globe there
was like
assuming atlantis is real and yeah
northwest mauritania you know
atlas the king of atlanta of mauritania
um
well joe biden do we know we could just
ask do we need another reset like that
for this system because i want to change
it i want to get these politicians out
of there ian are you saying
are you saying noah get the boat i don't
know
i don't know can we fix this human
system without something like that
happening
again i don't know you know to be honest
that's why the people want to push the
great reset yeah sounds like a great
research the great reset people are like
how do you stop
everyone just kind of eating themselves
to death and mass producing garbage
so the problem is whenever you have
someone who believes they're morally
right they know everything
and thus you need to purge or erase or
do something to other people
it never works out right and why should
i trust these people who are claiming
all this bad stuff's happening and we
need to make these changes
like so if you came to me and said maybe
we should have some kind of hard reset
i'm like i don't trust one person to
make that decision
well how do what do you do get all those
people out of office first of all
nadler schumer pelosi these questions
there's a 40 year old there is a famous
uh uh philosopher who had uh
i think some really great ideas he was a
french philosopher his name was what was
it it was a robespierre
uh yeah robespierre that guy i've been
studying the french revolution
heavily in the last few days so for
those that don't know uh so nazi
revolution you guys do you know who rob
sphere is
isn't he a rapper no but there should be
one
so uh if you if you don't know much
about the french revolution he was the
guy who went nuts
and was just like you you know you know
uh remember you ever seen episode of
simpsons where mr burns
says sings see my vest and he's singing
about all the animal parts he has for
his clothes and he's dancing he's really
happy
replace animal clothes with beheading
random people and that was robespierre
dancing around singing in the french
revolution and then finally when people
realize like yo this guy's kind of
killing too many people they were like
they killed him to stop it
like they're like this guy needs to be
blew his jaw off and let him
rot like lay there for three days and
suffer to die it was
horrible they hated him i was
complaining about him having good ideas
he was this young
really like lovable lawyer i think he
was a lawyer and he all he wanted was
freedom and democracy for the people
people loved him at first and he was
such a good guy and he went
crazy from the power which is killing
people like crazy i think people just
didn't realize he was a lawyer
and then when they found out then they
were like this guy's got to go
like wait he's a lawyer too so like i
could see if we
there there's a danger of becoming that
guy yeah there's a truck being like we
gotta get rid of all that so that we can
do something new
and so that yeah but you know what you
know the scary reality is
for zealots it's true robespierre wanted
something that couldn't exist so long as
people opposed him so he said kill those
who oppose me
and then they killed him because he was
killing too many people but with any any
one of these authoritarians or these
despots
people like kamala harris for instance
they have to get rid of those that are
obstructing them and they have no morals
they have no ethics
they'll say whatever do whatever and
they'll take power and then they'll
laugh on camera when asked about it for
no reason
you have to wonder why they're laughing
it's kind of weird but
a lot of it has to do with i mean fine
like like
we're smart people we know that these
people are useless
and so they're liars okay but but then
you look at somebody like say maxine
waters
congresswoman maxine waters who is
elected year
after year after year what has she done
for
for her district nothing nothing at all
and she's auntie maxine and people are
like oh we love her like
why what has she done for you it's the
same it's the same thing with aoc she
she had this list of a comp
of accomplishments like well i had a
bunch of town halls and
and i and i had like six amendments and
and i and i
introduced a whole bunch of bills that
didn't even see the house floor but
but you know real i was doing really
important work it's like no you weren't
you didn't weren't doing anything you
know what i would do
if i got elected to congress i would
just disrupt like crazy
tiny gavel it would just be yeah tiny
gavel banging it non-stop screaming
during sessions they'd have to remove me
filibuster nonstop just put up
everything on
would i would sleep all day so that i
could filibuster all night
i would they'd have a bill where like we
would like to rain in the post office
and i'd be like i'd like to sit here and
read the entire 5 500 omnimis
omnibus bill before we move forward it's
my time i would park my rv right outside
congress and just show up in my bathrobe
and just no there's dress isn't it
really yeah this is
kicked out in a heartbeat isn't there a
congresswoman that was just elected that
is also planning on bringing a fire
lauren bobert yeah
dress code
wants to bring her concealed lock but
you can't
there's an exception where members of
congress can can bring an
unloaded uh weapon in a case to their
office
but you can't bring it into the chamber
and uh
i see this house is changing in two
years you know what you know
you know what's kind of crazy though is
the uh uh so right now we have this big
uh protest coming to dc and trump
supporters
you know what they're posting on forums
they said they're advocating for
bringing weapons to the event
because they said the worst case
scenario is you gain legal standing in a
constitutional lawsuit against dc for
infringing on the right to bear arms
that is a bold statement that's a
seriously bold statement yeah
but that's like the the the rhetoric
coming from a lot of people who are
showing up in dc
is no joke thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time